ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 7a
bis 7c Beratung der Unterrichtung durch
die Bundesregierung über ihre digital
und ihre Giga
abit-strategie sowie Beratung des
Antrags der Fraktion der cdu/csu mit dem
Titel Stillstand und unklare
Zuständigkeiten in der digitalpolitik
beenden für eine ambitionierte und
koordinierte digitalstrategie für die
Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von 68
Minuten beschlossen ich eröffne die
Aussprache und das Wort hat für die
Bundesregierung der Bundesminister für
digitales und Verkehr dr Volker Wissing
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wer ins Ausland reist macht
häufig eine sehr ernüchternde Erfahrung
nämlich das andere beim Thema
Digitalisierung weiter sind als wir
beim Vergleich der 27 EU-Mitgliedstaaten
belegt die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
gerade mal Platz 13
das ist eine Bilanz die so nicht bleiben
kann das was wir übernommen haben von
der Vorgängerregierung im Bereich der
Digitalisierung kann sich nicht sehen
lassen Deutschland muss in der Top-Liga
spielen wir können uns Platz 13 nicht
leisten deshalb ist klar deutschland
braucht einen umfassenden digitalen
Aufbruch
das Kursbuch dafür ist die
digitalstrategie der Bundesregierung sie
führt erstmals die digitalpolitischen
Schwerpunkte aller Ministerien zusammen
und zeigt sehr konkret wie der Staat das
Leben der Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit
Hilfe der Digitalisierung verbessern
will und auch verbessern wird dabei
haben wir drei hebelprojekte definiert
die Grundlage für viele digitale
Anwendungen sind zum einen wäre das die
digitalen Identitäten denn um
datenbasierte Leistungen und Dienste im
Netz sicher nutzen zu können brauchen
wir sichere digitale Identitäten also
etwa bei online-behördengängen bei
Gesundheitsdienstleistungen beim
Beantragen des Personalausweises oder
auch im privatschaft wirtschaftlichen
Bereich etwa beim Online-Shopping beim
zweiten hebelprojekt geht es um
internationale Standards einheitliche
technische Standards ermöglichen
Interoperabilität das heißt sie sorgen
dafür dass alles zusammenpasst
wichtig ist daher dass wir die in
unserer Strategie beschriebenen Projekte
technisch offen und rechtlich sicher
gestalten das ist entscheidend für alle
digitalpolitischen Vorhaben die jedes
Ressort in eigener Verantwortung
umsetzen muss das dritte hebelprojekt
schließlich ist der gigabit-ausbau und
einer deutlichen
denn Daten sind der Schlüssel für
digitale Innovationen wenn man sie
analysiert aufbereitet verknüpft können
daraus ganz neue Geschäftsmodelle
entstehen neue Produktionsmöglichkeiten
und natürlich optimierte Abläufe darin
liegen Herausforderungen und Chance
gleichermaßen für den Standort
Deutschland deshalb setzen wir auf Open
Data also den grundsatzdaten öffentlich
für jedermann frei verfügbar und nutzbar
zu machen und wir setzen auf Datenräume
die in rechtssicheren Austausch von
Daten ermöglichen außerdem enthält
unsere digitalstrategie 18
Leuchtturmprojekte der einzelnen
Ressorts sie betreffen die
unterschiedlichsten Lebensbereiche und
tragen allesamt dazu bei dass die Dinge
bei uns künftig einfacher und
effizienter ablaufen dabei haben wir
konkrete Ziele definiert an denen wir
uns am Ende dieser Legislaturperiode im
Jahr 2025 messen lassen wollen
den Personalausweis beantragen einen
neuen Wohnort mitteilen oder ein neues
Unternehmen anmelden dass alles muss
künftig in wenigen Minuten vom Sofa aus
quasi von zu Hause aus erledigt werden
können daher sollen bis 2025
Personalausweis und Führerschein digital
auch auf dem Smartphone sein
im Gesundheitsbereich etwa wollen wir
erreichen dass mindestens 80 Prozent der
gesetzlich Versicherten die
elektronische Patientenakte nutzen und
bis fangen 2025 soll mindestens die
Hälfte aller Anschlüsse mit Glasfaser
versorgt sein und außerdem sollen alle
im Mobilfunk bis 2026 drahtlose Sprach-
und Datendienste verlässlich
flächendeckend nutzen können denn klar
ist Homeoffice Streaming im ICE und
empfangen auf der Berghütte müssen
endlich auch in Deutschland problemlos
möglich sein
dafür meine Damen und Herren haben wir
eine gigabit-strategie beschlossen mit
den darin enthaltenen Maßnahmen schaffen
wir die Bedingungen und die digitalen
Netze jetzt schneller und effizienter
auszubauen und wenn ich mir anschaue wie
das in den letzten Monaten vorangegangen
ist dann haben wir unsere Ziele schon
überfällt das läuft richtig gut und vor
allem müssen wir auch
Genehmigungsverfahren gemeinsam mit den
Ländern weiter vereinfachen und
beschleunigen beim Glasfaserausbau zum
Beispiel soll ein digitaler Antrag
ermöglicht werden zudem stärken wir
alternative Verlegetechniken mit denen
ein schneller Ausbau möglich ist unter
der Erde aber auch oberirdisch und gute
Nachrichten kommen in dem Zusammenhang
aus der Telekommunikationsbranche selbst
für die kommenden Jahre hat sie
Investitionen von 50 Milliarden Euro
angekündigt allein in den
Glasfaserausbau es ist unsere Aufgabe
dafür zu sorgen dass sie diese Mittel
schnell und zielführend investieren kann
denn der eigenwirtschaftliche Ausbau hat
für uns natürlich Vorrang vor
staatlicher Förderung
und meine Damen und Herren damit das
alles erfolgreich gelingt steuern und
begleiten wir die Umsetzung unserer
digitalstrategie mit einem Monitoring so
können wir beobachten und bewerten wie
wir mit der Umsetzung vorankommen und
wenn es hakt können wir rechtzeitig
nachsteuern wir wollen aber auch gerade
bei Maßnahmen mit großer Hebelwirkung
überprüfen ob sie effizient sind ob sie
tatsächlich effizient wirken das ist ein
wichtiger Schritt hin zu einem Lernenden
digitalen Staat einem Staat der
vorausschauend für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger arbeitet ich bin überzeugt dass
die
gigabit-strategie und die
digitalstrategie zusammen den digitalen
Aufbruch in Deutschland ermöglichen den
Aufbruch den unser Land dringend
benötigt damit schaffen wir
damit
schaffen wir mehr Teilhabe mehr Chancen
und mehr Fortschritt für alle und lassen
sie mich zum Schluss sagen weil ich
wahrscheinlich jetzt gleich von der
Opposition erfahren werde dass das alles
viel zu langsam gegangen ist in den
letzten 12 Monaten wir haben einen
Aufholbedarf weil sie uns die
Deutschland in einem Zustand
hinterlassen haben indem man feststellen
muss indem man feststellen muss dass wir
im digitalen in vielen Punkten erst am
Anfang stehen
der digitalminister Volker Wissing
stellt hier die digitalstrategie der
Bundesregierung vor auf 52 Seiten
zusammengetragen 18 Leuchtturmprojekte
und solche Selbstverständlichkeiten wie
Glasfaserkabel digitale
Verwaltungsleistung die in anderen
Ländern selbstverständlich sind die muss
der Minister jetzt
herbeischaffen bis 2025 will er 50%
Glasfaserkabel Nadine schön jetzt für
die Union Minister wissen sie lassen
sich in den letzten
Wochen hier dass sie sich nicht in
Zukunftsvisionen wie flugtaxis verlieren
wollen sondern ganz konkret den
Glasfaserausbau
ich finde das bemerkenswert denn ganz
ehrlich sie legen eine Strategie vor
sagen aber Visionen lehnen sie ab und da
frage ich mich wurde auf arbeiten sie
denn hin wie kann man denn eine
Strategie vorlegen wenn man das Ziel wo
man hin will gar nicht definiert
digitalpolitik ist weit mehr als
gigabit-ausbau digitalpolitik muss ich
einbetten in eine wirtschaftspolitische
Dimension in eine
gesellschaftspolitische Dimension eines
sicherheitspolitische und auch und das
merken wir doch in den letzten Monaten
massiv in eine geostrategische Position
und in dieser Situation zu sagen dass
interessiert mich gar nicht Visionen
damit habe ich nichts zu tun ich
definiere gar kein Ziel wo ich hin will
das finde ich schon sehr bemerkenswert
und das zweite Problem ist die Strategie
ist keine wirkliche Strategie bei jeder
Unternehmensstrategie finden Sie
Meilensteine Etappenzielen und
Kennzahlen und können danach auch
steuern wir haben zwar eben gehört dass
wir Ziele definiert haben aber entweder
sind diese Ziele so ambitionslos dass
jeder schon sieht dass man die sofort
erfüllen kann Stichwort Gigabit bis 25
in 50 Prozent der Haushalte am Montag
hatten wir Anhörung alle haben gesagt
naja das schafft er ja locker das ist ja
schon auf dem Weg das ist überhaupt
nicht ambitioniert oder auch im in
diesem desin-ranking der Europäischen
Kommission wo der Minister eben
kritisiert hat dass wir nur auf Platz 13
sind sein Ziel Platz 10 Frau schön
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
FDP-Fraktion
ja vielen Dank liebe Kolleginnen das
sind die Zwischenfrage zulassen sie
haben gerade kritisiert diese Strategie
sei zu ambitionslos und die Ziele die
darin definiert sein seien so gering
dass man sie ja locker erreichen können
und deshalb frage ich mich jetzt an der
Stelle einfach mal warum sind diese
Ziele denn nicht lange erreicht wenn die
so einfach zu erreichen gewesen wären
denn immerhin war es ja auch ihre
Fraktion die in den letzten Jahren die
Regierung unterstützt hat dabei
Digitalisierung nur zu verwalten statt
zu gestalten und da frage ich mich jetzt
wirklich wo liegt jetzt eigentlich der
Kern ihrer Kritik ist es nur dass sie
nicht selbst daran beteiligt waren diese
digitalstrategie jetzt vorzulegen oder
ist es tatsächlich fundiert dass ihnen
wirklich Visionen fehlen obwohl wir die
Grundlagen dafür noch nicht mal
geschaffen haben
liebe Frau Kollegin Conrad sie finden in
dieser Strategie quer durch alle Seiten
Ziele die die aus also Maßnahmen wo die
Ausgangslage genannt wird und dann steht
darin da wollen wir uns verbessern ohne
ein Zieldatum zu nennen wo sie denn
dahin kommen wollen sie haben bei der
Landwirtschaft wollen sie sich daran
messen lassen dass die Anwendung
digitaler Technologien in der
Landwirtschaft zugenommen hat ja um wie
viel denn sie sagen nicht wie viel
Fachkräfte wir mehr wollen sie sagen
nicht wie viel mehr Frauen wir in den
digitalberufen haben wollen sie sagen
nicht wie viel Unicorns werden unserem
Land brauchen damit sie das als Erfolg
deklarieren Sie sagen wir wollen von
allem mehr und das ist für sie dann ein
ambitioniertes Ziel ist es nicht die FDP
hat immer gesagt wir wollen greifbare
Ziele und wir wollen ein Monitoring und
davon ist ja kaum etwas zu finden
und liebe Kollegen Kollegen bei den
wirklichen Schlüsselthemen haben sie
jetzt schon nach einem Jahr einen
wahnsinnigen
Abkehr von dem was sie im
Koalitionsvertrag noch versprochen
hatten im Koalitionsvertrag und den
sondierungspapieren haben sie gesagt der
Schlüssel damit wir leistungsfähiger
sind in Zukunft ist das Thema Staats-
und verwaltungsdigitalisierung und
Monitor
Modernisierung so das teilen wir dieses
Anliegen in dieser Strategie findet man
kaum mehr etwas davon sie sagen wir
brauchen eine Eid teilen wir machen Sie
sie haben uns an ihrer Seite aber bei
allen anderen Themen der Staats- und
Verwaltungsmodernisierung machen sie das
weiter was wir vorgelegt haben es gibt
kaum neue Impulse im Gegenteil es droht
sogar ein Rückschritt denn lieber
Kollege Funke Kaiser wo sind denn die
Milliarden für die online für das
online-zugangsgesetz wir haben da
vorgelegt wir haben da jetzt was
aufgesetzt mit den Ländern dass wir alle
Verwaltungsdienstleistungen von
kennenlernt an und Kommunen
digitalisieren und wenn es da jetzt in
den nächsten Schritte gehen soll dann
braucht es auch eine Folgefinanzierung
sonst steht das Projekt sonst ruht das
Projekt und ich hoffe dass der
digitalminister sich für diese Themen
dann genauso einsetzt wie für Milliarden
im Verkehrsbereich denn sonst kann er
das Thema digitalminister an den Haken
hängen dann ist ein erster Linie
Verkehrsminister das Thema
Modernisierung und Digitalisierung des
Staates all das was sie eben auch
versprochen haben was die Menschen
spüren sollen in unserem Land braucht
eine finanzielle unerfütterung und
braucht auch den politischen Willen
dieser Regierung das zusammen mit
Ländern und Kommunen umzusetzen und
davon ist in dieser Strategie nichts zu
finden
[Applaus]
und ich will noch ein Wort zum Gigabit
Ausbaus sagen jetzt sagt der Minister
hier nach einem Jahr also das lief jetzt
super mit dem Ausbau vor Ort
wer ist dafür verantwortlich beruht das
etwa auf ihrem Handeln als
digitalminister sie haben noch überhaupt
nichts geändert beim Thema
gigabit-ausbau sie haben vor einem
halben Jahr eine Strategie vorgelegt
aber am Montag in der Anhörung hat man
uns bestätigt dass sie an fundamentalen
Änderungen noch überhaupt nichts gemacht
haben deshalb ist der Ausbau der jetzt
gerade passiert
beruht auf dem was wir was die
Vorgängerregierung gemacht hat
und jetzt haben sie eine neue Chance der
Minister hat gesagt er will einen vor
für alternativ alternative
verlegemethoden wo ist das Konzept wo
ist die Finanzierung wo ist dieser vor
ich sehe ihn nicht der Minister hat als
zweites Schlüsselthema genannt ein
schnelleren Ausbau eine schnellere
Planungsprozesse eine
Genehmigungsfiktion die finden wir schon
gar nicht mehr in dieser
digitalstrategie und beim Thema
planungsbeschleunigung zeigt der
Minister mit dem Finger auf die Länder
und sagt das müssen die doch
also von all dem was in den ersten Tagen
versprochen worden ist noch nichts
umgesetzt all das was jetzt an Ausbau
erfolgt Geduld auf den Gesetzen die wir
vorgelegt hatten haben und wir erwarten
dass wenn sie wirklich hier einen
Fortschritt haben wollen wenn Sie eine
Modernisierung haben wollen wenn Sie den
digitalen Aufbruch machen wollen den Sie
hier versprechen dass in all den Punkten
mehr Tempo gewinnen dass in all diesen
Punkten die Finanzierungs sichern und
dass sie sich vor allem als
digitalminister darum kümmern dass das
Monitoring passiert und das jedes Haus
eine Hausaufgaben macht das können wir
noch nicht erkennen wir werden genau
schauen und sie auch gerne dabei
unterstützen denn uns liegt auch der
digitale Aufbruch sehr am Herzen
Nadine schön stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende für diesen Bereich
der cdu/csu hier mit ihrer Kritik die
CDU CSU hat einen eigenen Antrag
eingebracht der fordert man ein
digitalministerium Bündelung von
Kompetenzen und mehr cybersicherheit in
der nicht Redner jetzt Detlef Müller für
die SPD die Digitalisierung prägt unser
Alltagsleben Punkt
egal ob er für die Fahrt mit der Bahn
online ein Ticket buchen im Homeoffice
arbeiten oder uns auch auf sozialen
Media Plattformen vernetzen wir befinden
uns in einer Welt in der die
Digitalisierung nicht mehr wegzudenken
ist und wir verlassen uns auf Sie doch
an vielen Stellen hakt das mit der
Digitalisierung in Deutschland noch
angefangen bei unzureichenden
Mobilfunkversorgung sie kennen das
sicherlich von der ein oder anderen
Bahnstrecke bis hin zu dem Bürgerämtern
zu denen man immer noch persönlich gehen
muss und beispielsweise einen neuen
Personalausweis zu beantragen
die Ampelkoalition hat sich deshalb zum
Ziel gesetzt die Digitalisierung endlich
auf die Höhe der Zeit zu bringen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Parlament
musste einige Zeit darauf warten aber
nun haben wir mit der digitalen und
gigabit-strategie zwei Vorlagen die die
wichtigsten Vorhaben in dieser
Legislaturperiode bündeln und einen
konkreten Weg aufzeigen wie unser Land
die Chancen der Digitalisierung nutzen
kann mit der gigabit-strategie wird der
Ausbau von Glasfaseranschlüssen
vorangetrieben und für schnelles
Internet bis an jedes Zuhause jede
Schule jedes Gewerbegebiet spricht man
durch bis eben an jede Milchkanne
gesorgt zudem stellen wir sicher
zudem stellen wir sicher dass der
neueste Mobilfunkstandard egal ob in die
Stadt oder auf dem Land bis sie im Jahr
2030 verfügbar sein wird in der
digitalstrategie hingegen finden sich
konkrete Vorhaben für alle Ministerien
die bis zum Jahr 2025 umgesetzt werden
sollen konkret und für alle Ministerien
es ist die digitalpolitische
Prioritätenliste dieser Legislatur dazu
gehört insbesondere die Digitalisierung
der Verwaltung Verwaltung wird nach
Umsetzung davor haben viel
serviceorientierter und damit nahe an
den Bedürfnissen der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ausgerichtet sein so werden wir
beispielsweise dafür sorgen dass
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Informationen
Nachweise für
Verwaltungsdienstleistungen digital und
damit nur ein einziges Mal bereitstellen
müssen Personalausweis und Führerschein
der Minister sprach davon endlich
digital werden und rentenübersichten
beispielsweise elektronisch zur
Verfügung stehen
zur digitalstrategie gehört auch die
Digitalisierung unserer Infrastruktur
und natürlich auch der Schiene dann sind
wir erreichen des deutschlandpaktes
braucht es neben der Sanierung dem
Ausbau des Schienennetzes eine
flächendecke flächendeckende digitale
leit- und Sicherungstechnik damit wir
die Kapazität auf dem Streckennetz
erhöhen können gleiches gilt auch für
die Mobilität auf der Höhe der Zeit auch
hier müssen wir in einem fairen Rahmen
mehr Daten zur Verfügung stellen um den
Weg für die Entwicklung neuer und vor
allem effizienterer Mobilitätslösungen
zu ebnen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
klar ist aber auch all die genannten
Vorhaben benötigen zur Umsetzung eine
entsprechende finanzielle Untersetzung
wenn wir als mit der Priorisierung
dieser Maßnahmen und digital ist besser
ernst meinen braucht es ein ein und das
vereinbarte digital Budget
Herr Minister kann man das so ein
bisschen lassen Sie uns das dass
digitalbudget gemeinsam und vor allem
schnell auf den Weg bringen meine Damen
und Herren
nun müssen sowohl die digitalstrategie
als auch die gigabit-strategie in die
Tat umgesetzt werden damit die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dieses Landes
endlich Digitalisierung auf der höhere
Zeit nutzen können
nicht alles geht schnell nicht alles
geht auch mir schnell genug nicht alles
ist auch jetzt schon perfekt aber wir
haben endlich eine gute Grundlage Frau
schön die Basics schaffen wir jetzt
damit das was wir lange vergessen haben
nicht geschafft dann schaffen wir jetzt
eine gute Grundlage für den Aufbruch ins
digitale Zeit aber vielen Dank
Detlef Müller in der SPD die ihr die
Region mitträgt mit einem wichtigen
Hinweis es steht nichts von Geld in der
ganzen Strategie und in den jetzigen
Zeiten und bei diesem wichtigen Thema
musste man dafür kämpfen dass das mit
Geld unterfüttert wird das hat er
zumindest den Minister geraten Barbara
Lenk jetzt für die AFD frau Präsidentin
sehr verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sehr geehrter Herr Minister
endlich könnte man rufen endlich was
lange währt wird endlich gut oder etwa
doch nicht die Ampel hat vollmundig im
Koalitionsvertrag eine digitalstrategie
angekündigt und endlich hat das
Bundeskabinett während seiner Klausur
auf Schloss Meseberg nun tatsächlich so
etwas wie eine digitalstrategie
verabschiedet
die Antwort auf die Frage was genau
eigentlich Digitalisierung ist erhält
man beim Lesen der digitalen Strategie
nicht
hier hat man so schön klingende
Schlagworte wie glasfaser-infrastruktur
digitale Identitäten oder ki-leuchttürme
dieses Potpourri an Elementen macht aber
noch keine echte digitalstrategie aus
und was genau meine Damen und Herren ist
denn eine feministische digitalpolitik
kommen wir wieder zu ihrer Vorlage
die einzelnen Ressorts behalten weiter
ihre digitalkompetenzen ein Gerangel um
Zuständigkeiten ist somit noch weiterhin
wahrscheinlich
und das digitalministerium fehlt noch
immer
[Musik]
es ist durchaus positiv anzumerken dass
sich die Koalition bis Ende der 20
Legislatur an bestimmten Punkten zum
Erreichen der Ziele messen lassen will
zum Teil werden hier schon harte Zahlen
genannt beispielsweise sollen mindestens
80 Prozent der gesetzlich
Krankenversicherten über eine
elektronische Patientenakte verfügen zum
Teil bleiben die Kriterien jedoch sehr
schwammig meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren vieles aber bei dieser Strategie
bleibt niveaulos so schreibt die
Koalition
aufbauend auf Smart City und smart
Redens Modellprojekten ermöglichen wir
digitale Lösungen für bessere
Visualisierung von
Planungsentscheidungen leider wird hier
nicht weiter gedacht in Richtung einer
kohärten Smart Cities Strategie welche
eine digitale Verwaltung mit einschließt
dies wurde von unserer Fraktion bereits
in der letzten Legislatur gefordert
in vielen Sätzen meine Damen und Herren
lese ich das Wörtchen soll
das lässt für mich den Schluss zu dass
so manche Maßnahmen der digitalstrategie
vielleicht unter Finanzierungsvorbehalt
steht ist das vielleicht ein Grund dafür
dass auf über 50 Seiten kaum konkrete
Projekte mit Verantwortlichkeiten
aufgelistet werden und auch das
digitalbudget fehlt immer noch
und schließlich bei Monitoring der
vorliegenden digitalstrategie soll der
digitalrat eine beratende Rolle
wahrnehmen
während es nicht besser dieses
scheintote Gremium endlich aufzulösen
und damit das Kompetenz für war bei der
digitalpolitik ein wenig zu lichten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen außer
Spesen nichts gewesen eine kohärente
digitalstrategie können wir als
afd-fraktion jedenfalls nicht erkennen
es ist positiv dass ein Anfang gemacht
ist aber das ganze Konstrukt muss nun
mit Leben gefüllt werden wenn
Deutschland
konkurrenzfähig bleiben soll besten Dank
Barbara Lenk für die AFD kritisierte
unter anderem dass es kein
digitalministerium gibt das kritisiert
auch die cdu/csu ja und das mit der
feministischen digitalpolitik sei mal
dahingestellt Mike außendorf jetzt der
digitalpolitische Gespräch
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit der
digital- und gigabit-strategie sind für
einen großen Schritt nach vorne gekommen
jetzt kann es losgehen mit der
Digitalisierung der Gesellschaft an der
Stelle gestanden sie aber Herr Minister
Wissing doch eine kleine kritische
Anmerkung wir haben in den Prozess immer
wieder angemerkt dass für die
Digitalisierung der Gesellschaft wir
auch die Zivilgesellschaft und die
Verbände Einwände einbinden müssen das
werden wir auch weiter fordern und Frau
Kahn wir gleich vorstellen wie wir uns
das vorstellen aber jetzt können wir zu
den positiven Dingen es ist wirklich
eine Strategie und wenn wir uns
anschauen welche drei hebelprojekte
benannt sind dann sehen wir auch warum
es im Namen Strategie verdient weil wir
nämlich hier gucken was müssen wir
zuerst tun um dann die Potenziale zu
heben und da möchte ich einige wichtige
Punkte nennen das ist zunächst die
elektronische Identität also die
Weiterentwicklung des elektronischen
Personalausweises damit sich Bürgerinnen
und Bürger online sicher zertifizieren
können und Geschäfte und Firmen Prozesse
anbieten können damit eben auch online
das sicher genutzt werden kann durch
weite Teile der
wir haben dann das Konzept zu
Nutzbarmachung der Daten das ist das
Stichwort dateninstitut damit die
Datenmengen die in vielen Unternehmen in
Einrichtungen auch in Regierungsstellen
schlummern genutzt werden können und
zwar sicher und anonymisiert zu
Entwicklung neuer Geschäftsmodelle von
Start-ups von Forschung von kleinen
Firmen und vor allen Dingen Richtung
Nachhaltigkeit denn das ist der weitere
große Punkt der für uns hier vorzuheben
ist digitale Nachhaltigkeit das
umweltdatenportal ist auf unsere
Initiative hineingekommen in die
Strategie und an dem Punkt werden wir
Grüne weiterarbeiten damit wir eben die
Potenziale wirklich nutzen können um die
digitale Transformation Richtung
Nachhaltigkeit und Klimaneutralität
weiterzuentwickeln
was ist aber die Grundlage für all die
Konzepte die in der Regel in der
digitalstrategie genannt ist das sind
leistungsfähige Netze und was wir
wirklich brauchen ist schnelles Internet
in jedem Haus und an jeder Milchkanne
der nur so schaffen wir die
Voraussetzung für intelligente Lösungen
wie zum Beispiel digitale Rufbusse die
per App geruft werden können um im
vorstädtischen Raum und im ländlichen
Raum die Mobilität zu verbessern oder
automatisierte Bewässerung die in der
Landwirtschaft bei Auswertung von Wetter
und bodendaten den Ressourceneinsatz
effizienter gestaltet so und bei der
gewerbestrategie da stimmt wirklich
alles es sind viele grüne Akzente
reingekommen der Vorrang für
unterversorgte Gebiete ist ganz wichtig
und Frau schön jetzt muss ich noch mal
auf Sie zurückkommen sie haben ja gesagt
dass sei ein Ergebnis ihrer Arbeit das
ist aber auch das Ergebnis dass wir
weiße Flecken im Mobilfunk auf dem Land
haben nämlich weil der Scheuer und die
Union die Frequenzvergabe so gestaltet
haben dass die Unternehmen nicht in der
Pflichten flächendeckend auszubauen und
deswegen brauchen wir jetzt auch noch
eine staatliche Mobilfunk
Infrastrukturgesellschaft
mit ja wir uns jetzt rumschlagen müssen
also da Frau schön haben sie wirklich
ein Eigentor geschossen
so dann ganz wichtig digitalbudget das
haben wir im Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart das muss jetzt wirklich
kommen damit wir loslegen können die
Zuständigkeiten sind geklärt endlich
muss ich sagen das ist gut wir können
jetzt also die Zukunftsprojekte
Digitalisierung aufnehmen und das möchte
ich auch noch sagen Digitalisierung ist
ja kein Selbstzweck wir setzen
Digitalisierung intelligent ein für
Erleichterung im digitalen und analogen
Alltag der Menschen und für die
Transformation hin zu einer nachhaltigen
und klimaneutralen Gesellschaft
mike außendorf ist der digitalpolitische
Sprecher der bündnisgründiger Teil der
Bundesregierung sind und es war eine
bemerkenswerte Rede denn er begann diese
Rede mit einer Kritik an dem
ftp-minister die Digitalisierung er
sollte da die gesellschaftlichen
Gruppierungen mehr einbringen Anke
Domstadt Berg für die Linksfraktion sie
ist die Sprecherin für digitalpolitik
ihrer Fraktion
sehr geehrte Präsidentin liebe
kolikinnen meine letzte Rede hier
schloss ich mit folgendem Fazit zur
digitalstrategie sie enthält keine
Vision die beschreibt was man mit ihr
eigentlich erreichen will aber dafür
viele schwammige Ziele
Verantwortung bleibt weiterhin völlig
konfus verteilt und ihr fehlen immer
noch Ressourcen denn das digitalbudget
gibt es ja noch nicht vor allem aber
beantwortet sie die Frage nicht was will
man denn konkret jetzt eigentlich anders
machen als die Gokus vorher die ja auch
schöne Ziele formulierten aber nie
erreichten am Ende geht es nämlich
umzusetzen was man verspricht und da
hatte ich meine Zweifel die Beteiligung
der Zivilgesellschaft fand nämlich trotz
Koalitionsvertrag Versprechen nicht
statt wie meine schriftliche Frage ergab
auf die digitalstrategie mit dem wohl
nicht zufällig wirtschaftsfreundlichen
Titel digitale Werte schöpfen nahmen 18
mal Lobbyisten der Wirtschaft Einfluss
darunter allein erste Mal der Lobbyisten
Verband dagegen gab es kein einziges
Gespräch mit der digitalen
Zivilgesellschaft von Chaos Computerclub
bis Wikimedia und erst recht nicht mit
der sonstigen Zivilgesellschaft zum
Beispiel Senioren Behinderten sozial
oder Verbraucherschutzverbänden das
zeigt wesseninteressen diese
digitalstrategie tatsächlich vertreten
soll und das ist ein unerträglicher
Zustand meine Damen und Herren
auch die gigabit-strategie ist ein
wirtschaftslobbyismus Papier von der
ersten bis zur letzten Seite der Markt
soll alles richten auch wenn genau
dieser Markt aus Deutschland ein Land
des lahmen Internets und der Funklöcher
gemacht hat und laut der
gigabit-strategie Minister Wissing
führte die bisherige Regulierung zu
einem funktionierenden Infrastruktur und
Dienste Wettbewerb ich lade Sie sehr
gern mal in die Ostprignitz ein da
stehen nämlich Funklöcher an Wettbewerb
miteinander und nicht Dienste Anbieter
überhaupt
Wettbewerb auf infrastrukturebene das
ist so ziemlich das Dümmste was man
machen kann niemand niemand würde sich
mehrere Abwasserkanäle oder
Gasanschlüsse in ein Haus legen aber bei
Glasfaser soll sowas Sinn machen es gibt
nicht genug tiefbaukapazitäten und
Fachkräfte aber diese Giga wird
Strategie toleriert dass wir weiter
mehrfach eine Straße aufreißen und
manche Orts zwei Glasfaser nebeneinander
zu legen obwohl das Dorfleben an immer
noch gar nichts hat nicht einmal wo eine
Kommune ein völlig offenes Glasfasernetz
verlegt hat dass maximale
wettbewerbsfreiheit bietet will diese
Bundesregierung den Überbau untersagen
sie spielt auf Zeit und will erstmal
2023 den Überbau evaluieren die gleiche
gigabit-strategie behauptet aber man
will Ressourcen sparen
Infrastrukturausbau das ist Greenwashing
und das lassen wir ihn nicht durchgehen
mit dieser gigabit-strategie macht sich
die Bundesregierung auch zum
Vertriebsmitarbeiter für große
telco-konzerne eine info-kampagne soll
es geben zur Anregungen der Nachfrage
nach gigabit-netzen Zitate aus der
Strategie Gutscheine soll es geben zur
Anregung der Nachfrage nach inhouse
Verkabelung ein 215 Millionen schweres
5g Innovationsprogramm soll die
Nachfrage von Kommunen und Unternehmen
anregen und die Ampel will
digitalmanager in Landkreisen bezahlen
die man ahnt es nachfrageanregen soll
und 5g Vorhaben in ihren Landkreisen
initiieren soll ich sag mal was das
heißt diese digitalmanager werden mit
Steuergeld dafür bezahlt Aufträge für
Konzerne zu beschaffen die mit
Steuergeld von den Kommunen bezahlt
werden das ist ein Fall für die heute-
völlig irre wird es aber im Abschnitt
Evaluation der Fördermaßnahmen ergibt
sie nämlich das vor 2030 das Ziel
gigabit-anschlüsse für alle erreichbar
sein sollte nennt diese Ampel das
Überforderung und will den Ausbau sofort
Bremsen Bremsen mit antragsstopps und
Quotierungen der Förderungen denkt man
im bmdv auf ein paar Jahre mehr oder
weniger lahmes Netz in der Ostprignitz
oder im Sauerland kommt es nicht an
Hauptsache bei Konzernen klingelt der
Geldbeutel lauter und länger das ist
Menschen und fortschrittsfeindliche
Politik und das wird die Linksfraktion
nicht unterstützen vielen Dank
schalte Berg einen Punkt will ich
herausheben die tief tiefbaukapazitäten
und die Fachkräfte hat sie angesprochen
ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt es gibt
tatsächlich in Deutschland viel zu wenig
Firmen die diese Kabel verlegen und an
Fachkräften fehlt es ohne hin Maximilian
Funke Kaiser jetzt für die FDP
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Bundesminister liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe Union
ganz ehrlich bei der Lektüre Ihres
Antrags mit dem Titel und ich zitiere
Stillstand und zuständigkeitschaos und
der digitalpolitik beenden für eine
ambitionierte und koordinierte
digitalstrategie da musste ich schon ein
bisschen schmunzeln denn das hat denn
die Union die letzten eineinhalb
Jahrzehnte in diesem Bereich vorzuweisen
richtig rein gar nichts zugestanden
Scheinheiligkeit das können Sie den
Stillstand den haben allerdings sie zu
verantworten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sie haben zig Strategien
verabschiedet sie haben sechs Strategien
verabschiedet haben den zweiten Schritt
vor dem ersten Schritt gemacht sie haben
digitalpolitik in der digitalpolitik bei
jeder Wahl bundland Kommune den Menschen
das Blaue vom Himmel versprochen
übersetzt sie haben mit dem Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern 16 Jahre lang Bullshit
Schaufenster Bullshit Bingo gespielt
ohne die wirklich wichtigen Schritte in
diesem Land anzugehen und das hat mit
dieser digitalen Strategie jetzt ein
Ende weil wir machen jetzt Tempo
der liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
wollen die Digitalisierung voranbringen
und das machen wir auch mit dieser
digitalstrategie denn sie packt an den
Wurzeln des Problems an denn anders als
bisherige digitalstrategien ist die
nicht mehr ein reines Sammelsurium an
Einzelvorhaben sie ist eine Strategie
die an den Grundlagen anpackt Grundlagen
die wir eigentlich schon längst
gebraucht hätten und das sind diese drei
hebelprojekte Punkt eins wir brauchen
Highspeed Netz das ist eigentlich
traurig dass wir das im Jahre 2022
überhaupt noch da reinschreiben müssen
ohne schnelles Internet keine
Digitalisierung deswegen die
gigabit-strategie wir brauchen eine
einheitliche Dateninfrastruktur eine
einheitliche datenspare denn auch da
ohne Daten keine Digitalisierung und wir
brauchen eine sichere und
nutzerfreundliche digitale Identität
denn sie ist das Tor für jeden einzelnen
Menschen in die digitale Welt
und was mir dabei wirklich sehr sehr
wichtig ist das wurde auch schon gesagt
das ist alles kein Selbstwert wir machen
das um den Wohlstand von morgen zu
sichern wir machen das um nachhaltig zu
werden wir machen das um den Menschen in
diesem Land das Leben zu erleichtern und
machen wir uns nichts vor durch die
Pandemie und durch den ukrainekrieg
müssen jetzt Entscheidungen für die
Zukunft dieses Landes getroffen werden
und dabei geht es auch um
Standortbedingungen und
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit in diesem Land denn
ja wir erleben eine Zeitenwende und
genau in einer solchen Zeit brauchen wir
eine Neubegründung unseres Landes
effiziente Verwaltung moderne
Gesundheitsversorgung leistungsfähige
Infrastruktur das digitale wird diese
Neubegründung ermöglichen warum weil wir
Zeit sparen weil wir Geld sparen und
weil wir auch dazu noch den Klimaschutz
beispielsweise ermöglichen das kann und
das wird das neue Geschäftsmodell für
den Wohlstand unserer Generation von
morgen und es ist unsere Pflicht dass
wir das jetzt machen denn am Ende geht
es um deine Erfolg der nachfolgenden
Generationen dafür steht diese Strategie
und dafür die Politik der Freien
Demokraten herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
DR reinhard Brandl
frau Präsidentin verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen liebe Herr Funke Kaiser in
welcher Welt leben sie überhaupt welches
Dokument haben Sie denn gelesen das was
sie jetzt gerade angesprochen haben
nämlich die digitalstrategie ist doch
genau das es ist keine Strategie sondern
das ist ein Sammelsurium an
Einzelprojekten die weitgehend
zusammenhangslos sind und wissen Sie
wie ein solches Dokument entsteht das
kann ich Ihnen genau beschreiben man
fragt alle Ressorts ab und sagt bitte
nennt mir eure drei populärsten Projekte
und dann kopiert man den Rücklauf
zusammen und setzt ein paar
Überschriften drüben aber ein richtiger
digitalminister muss mehr leisten als
copy-pace
und Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Herr Funke Kaiser Herr Funke Kaiser sie
haben gesagt wir gehen nicht an den
Ursachen
das wichtigste für die digitalstrategie
wäre doch dass man sich mal überlegt
woran der vielen öffentlichen
Digitalisierungsprojekte in der
Vergangenheit gescheitert sind und es
lag nicht daran dass die FDP nicht
regiert hat es lag nicht einen guten
Ideen die gab schon vorher es lag auch
nicht am Geld und an den Mitarbeiter
sondern es lag es lag an nicht
getroffenen Entscheidungen und es lag an
unklaren Rahmenbedingungen und mit
dieser Strategie entscheiden Sie
original nichts weil wir würden denn
gern wissen wo steht denn die Ampel zum
Beispiel im Spannungsfeld Freiheit und
Sicherheit wie halten Sie es denn mit
dem Föderalismus wir wissen doch genau
wir wissen alle dass er Föderalismus so
sehr wie ihr ihn lieben mit einer der
Hauptursachen ist warum die
verwaltungsdigitalisierung in vielen
Bereichen nicht funktioniert wir wollen
Sie denn mit den großen
internetkonzernen umgehen Google
Microsoft Amazon das ist doch der große
elef der weiße Elefant im Raum wollen
sie kooperieren oder wollen Sie sich
unabhängig machen all das sind
ungeklärte Richtungsentscheidungen die
uns die Regierung
getroffen hat und ich halte das
verantwortungslos sie hatten jetzt in
Meseberg die Chance ein Paket zu bilden
all diese Entscheidungen auf einmal zu
treffen und ehrlich gesagt wäre schon
fast egal wie sie entscheiden hauptsache
sie würden entscheiden weil dann hätte
man nämlich eine Richtung und mit der
Richtung könnten alle mal loslaufen aber
mit ihrer Strategie in der Hand Herr
Wissing läuft doch keiner los weil hat
er nicht mal Geld dabei ist ja gar nicht
klar ob es finanziert wird und meine
Damen und Herren meine Damen und Herren
sie hatten im Koalitionsvertrag eine
gute Idee nämlich den das digitalbudget
aber es steht nicht im Haushalt der 2022
und es steht nicht im Haushalt der 2023
wann wollen Sie dann mit anfangen wenn
die Wahl vorbei ist wir haben es
beantragt sie haben es abgelehnt und
wissen Sie die genaue Begründung sie
können sich nicht einigen wer was
bekommt
es heißt aber das sind Summe niemand
etwas bekommt und so kommt die
Digitalisierung in Deutschland auch
nicht voran
und was mich wirklich
was mich wirklich besorgt ist dass sie
die größte das größte Risiko für die
Digitalisierung in Deutschland mit
keinem Wort erwähnen
99 Prozent der modernen sieben
nanometer-chips kommen heute aus Taiwan
und aus Südkorea wenn diese Lieferkette
einmal abreißt dann kommt kein neuer
Computer mehr in Deutschland an dann
läuft kein Auto mehr vom Band und auch
sonst wird noch viel mehr nichts mehr
produziert und meine Damen und Herren
ist es richtig es ist gut dass Intel im
Magdeburg investiert aber das alleine
reicht nicht wir müssen die gesamten
Wertschöpfungsketten im
Halbleiterbereich in den Blick nehmen
und davon sehe ich und höre ich von der
Ampel original gar nicht weder von Herrn
Wissing noch von Herrn
wird sich jetzt auf der Regierungsbank
wahrscheinlich denken wovon redet dieser
Brandl überhaupt
ich bin
da ich bin auf der Chips gar nicht
zuständig gebaut und die Straße nach
Magdeburg aber das Problem hat wir sind
eine stimmt in Wirklichkeit sind sehr
für fast nichts zuständig wir haben es
mal ausgewertet 18 Prozent der Aufgaben
im Bereich Digitalisierung sind in ihrem
Haus ich sage es mal vorsichtig mit
einem Projekt 18 hat die FDP keine gute
Erfahrung in der Vergangenheit
ich hoffe mal das ist kein
schlechtes Omen denn wir brauchen
eigentlich einen starken digitalminister
wir brauchen eine echte digitalstrategie
und wir brauchen endlich
Richtungsentscheidungen in der
Digitalisierung weil so wie sie arbeiten
so wird es nichts
sagte reinhard Brandl der
digitalpolitische Sprecher der CDU CSU
er warf dem Bundesminister vorher was er
vorgelegt habe seinen Sammelsurium ein
Einzelprojekt in der Tat ist Teil der
Strategie sind 19 sogenannte
Leuchtturmprojekte Jens Zimmermann jetzt
der digitalpolitische Sprecher der
SPD-Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zu Beginn dieser
Legislaturperiode habe ich hier gesagt
wir wollen es nicht nur besser machen
wir müssen es auch anders machen und ich
glaube die Rede vom Kollegen Brandl hat
es eben noch mal eindrucksvoll unter
Beweis gestellt warum das dringend
notwendig ist liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
unsere Strategie mit der wollen wir
Sicherheit in dieser schwierigen Zeit
des Wandels der er an vielen vielen
Stellen uns momentan beschäftigt
schaffen und ich finde das machen wir
auch denn dazu gehört natürlich da sind
sich alle Rednerinnen und Redner hier
einig ein digitaler Aufbruch und der
braucht eben
Aufbruch bei der Infrastruktur das ist
das was mein Kollege Detlef Müller
gesagt hat das sind unsere Hausaufgaben
da gibt es überhaupt keine Diskussionen
drüber und wir brauchen aber auch ein
schönes neues Wort das dieser Tage
überall genannt wird wir brauchen
Resilienz das heißt wir müssen unsere
Gesellschaft digital fest und sicher
machen gerade in Zeiten dieser Konflikte
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ja diese Strategie ist kein
Sammelsurium von Wolkenkuckucksheim
sondern wir haben ganz klare
Themenfelder identifiziert wo wir gesagt
haben da müssen wir Prioritäten setzen
denn da ist die große Hebelwirkung drin
und ich will nur mal drei nennen das ist
das Thema natürlich digitale
Infrastruktur ich habe keine Lust mehr
wenn ich Freitags hier aus Berlin mit
dem Zug rausfahre dass an der
Stadtgrenze Berlin der Mobilfunk
abbricht da sind wir uns auch alle einig
aber es muss eben jetzt auch erledigt
werden liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir haben das Thema öffentliche
Verwaltung Digitalisierung der
Verwaltung da haben wir das Thema der
digitalen Identität definiert und das
ist ja leider ein Projekt wo wir in der
vergangenen Legislaturperiode den
richtigen Impuls aus dem Kanzleramt
hatten aber leider am Ende das Ding
unbedingt noch vor der Bundestagswahl
gestartet werden musste und es war ein
weiterer rohrkrippierer leider muss ich
sagen von Andy scheuer und
als drittes Projekt mit Hebelwirkung das
ist dieser Tage glaube ich allen klar
ist wir müssen international standards
setzen denn gemeinsam mit vielen
Nationen auf der Welt so wie es auch der
Bundeskanzler diese Woche in New York
gemacht hat Verbündete zu suchen auch im
digitalen Raum das ist wichtiger denn je
und deswegen will diese Koalition und
wird diese Koalition ein Schwerpunkt bei
der internationalen Normen und
standardsetzung setzen das ist ganz
entscheidend gerade in diesen Zeiten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und weil es eben diese Sicherheit im
Wandel braucht müssen wir unsere
Gesellschaft eben auch sicher machen
gegen die Feinde von außen wenn wir
sehen Cyberangriffe wir brauchen bei der
IT-Sicherheit mehr mehr Initiativen aber
es geht eben auch darum unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu befähigen Fake
News zu erkennen immun zu werden gegen
Manipulation von außen und die
problematisch das ist das sehen wir doch
wenn wir hören das Putin 300 Millionen
Euro investiert hat um Demokratien in
Europa zu destabilisieren und wenn ich
mir die Wahlen in Italien gerade
anschaue was da online alles passiert
dann wird es doch deutlich um was es da
geht in Italien und da wird mir schlecht
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
da wird mir schlecht wenn ich dann
Manfred Weber den
oberkonservativen aus dem Europäischen
Parlament an der Seite von Silvio
Berlusconi und den Postfaschisten sehe
das kann doch nicht sein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dann müssen Sie
doch auch mal dazu was sagen
und genau das ist eben auch Teil unserer
digitalstrategie weil warum macht man
denn so was warum trifft sich denn der
Berlusconi mit dem Manfred Weber damit
er es am Ende digital einsetzen kann um
seiner eigenen Bevölkerung weiß zu
machen die Freunde Putins die in Italien
an die Macht wollen das sind eigentlich
ganz normale konservative da wäre Alice
Weidel der linke Flügel in dieser Partei
meine Damen und Herren und da sind sie
zu Recht sprachlos herzlichen Dank
Jens Zimmermann war das der Bundestag
der debattiert seit heute morgen um 9
Uhr die digital und gigabak mit
Strategie der Bundesregierung vorgelegt
vom zuständigen Minister Wissing und
jetzt Eugen Schmidt für die AFD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidenten
die Tiere Erlaubnis zitiere ich aus der
digitalstrategie der Bundesregierung wir
wollen breitbandige
mobilkommunikationssysteme zu jeder Zeit
an jedem Ort und Glasfaser bis zum
Hausanschluss flächendeckend 2010
das war ein Zitat aus dem
Aktionsprogramm der Bundesregierung von
jetzt will man dasselbe plötzlich erst
2030 schaffen ja sie hatte Bürger 22
Jahre später fällt diese Regierung ein
dass sie noch 20 Jahre länger braucht
dieselbe und seriöse Regierung die Ihnen
durch Tipps geben will
ich frage sie von der Regierung wieso
sollen die Bürger ihren Plänen
ausgerechnet jetzt glauben schenken
wieso Benehmen sie nicht die Gründe für
die Verzögerung
kein Wort dazu in ihrem Papierchen
dann ihr wir es Gerede von digitaler
Souveränität ohne überhaupt zu sagen von
wem sie sich unabhängig machen wollen
sie trauen
die USA oder China zu erwähnen
2018 wollten sie Deutschland noch zum
Leitmarkt für 5g entwickeln
haben sie sich mal gefragt warum sie mit
ihrem geduldigen Papieren ständig
scheitern
die zentrale Frage ist die von Bildung
des eigenen Volkes sie sprechen selbst
von Ausbau von Kompetenzen in
Schlüsseltechnologien aber
Mikrochips KI und Quantenrechner lernt
man nicht inklusiven für menisismus
genderseminar
sie betreiben die aus Gründung von
Leistungsträgern und für untreuung von
Steuergeld an gender Trojas und
politaugendnisse in Staat und enjios sie
betreiben die Massenzuwanderung von
Analphabeten also sind sie auch direkt
für den Rückschritt verantwortlich
in den in den deutschen steckt
unglaubliches Potenzial sie von der
Regierung machen das nicht
ihr gefahren von Chancengerechtigkeit
führt eben nicht zu einer Zitat
spitzenrolle im Weltlauf
sondern zum technischen Niveau der
schrottampel mit drei Lämpchen und vier
Transistoren
Deutschland wird auch nicht erfolgreich
wenn wir Chinas total überwachen
kopieren
erfolgreich sind wir dann wenn wir unser
eigenes Volk aktivieren warum sollten
qualifizierte deutsche überhaupt im Land
bleiben wenn Heimat Herkunft und folgt
doch beliebig sind ich sage ihnen ihr
Plan wird scheitern
danke
ja ich weiß nicht sie haben es
wahrscheinlich nicht gesehen Volker
Wissing hat den Kopf geschüttelt
ausgerechnet dem liberalen eine
Totalüberwachung des deutschen Volkes
als Ziel vorzuwerfen ist in der Tat
gewagt Miesbach kann jetzt
die nächste Rednerin hier ist im
Ausschuss für digitales von den
bündnisgründen
Absichtserklärung gab es in der
Vergangenheit eigentlich schon genug und
eigentlich
steht im Koalitionsvertrag auch schon
alles oder zumindest fast alles was wir
für richtig halten aber gut wenn wir
jetzt eine digitalstrategie brauchen
damit sich Deutschland von seinen
Faxgeräten verabschiedet dann sei dem
ebenso
digitalpolitik ist Gesellschaftspolitik
und mit welchen Prioritäten wir in den
nächsten Jahren eben diese
digitalpolitik gestalten macht ein
relevanten Unterschied dabei
wer davon profitiert und Frau Lenk wenn
sie jetzt aufpassen dann lernen Sie
etwas
[Applaus]
es macht nämlich ein relevanten
Unterschied vorhandene macht
Ungleichheit die in dieser Gesellschaft
existiert und die von einigen hier in
dem Haus auch jemand verteidigt wird die
gibt es und es macht es macht dann einen
Unterschied wenn wir erkennen dass es
eine Gefahr ist dass diese Macht und
Gleichheit besteht wir müssen also
unsere digitalpolitik gerechter machen
wir müssen sie barrierefreier machen und
wir müssen sie gemeinwohlorientierter
machen uns geht es um den Schutz von
marginalisierten Gruppen uns geht es um
Grundrechte und Menschenrechte und gibt
es uns Nachhaltigkeit uns geht es um
Sozialpolitik und uns geht es eben auch
um eine intersekten intersektionalen
Feminismus
du hast gerade Demokratie erwähnt ja
auch darum geht es uns denn
Digitalisierung erschöpft sich für uns
nicht bei der Frage um schnelles
Internet wenn es um unseren Kern geht
dann geht es um unsere demokratischen
Grundwerte die wir auch in der digitalen
Welt verteidigen wollen
und deshalb muss unsere digitalpolitik
zwingend eine intersektionale und eine
feministische digitalpolitik sein
unsere Welt ist auch zu komplex für
quickfixes zu oft schauen wir auf ein
gesellschaftliches Problem und Glauben
mit einer coolen App oder mit mehr
Überwachung wird alles gut aber das ist
nur Symptombekämpfung und es ist
technologische fleckshustereien
stattdessen brauchen wir eine
digitalpolitik die die
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Auswirkungen in
den Blick nimmt und eben dieser Fokus
macht einen relevanten Unterschied wenn
wir zum Beispiel diskutieren über die
chatkontrolle oder über digitale
Identitäten und darum geht es uns wenn
wir von einer intersektionalen an einer
feministischen digitalpolitik sprechen
dass die Idee der dass die Idee der
feministischen digitalpolitik jetzt in
der digitalstrategie verankert ist ist
deshalb richtig und wichtig und ein
relevanter Anfang aber dabei kann es
nicht bleiben was wir jetzt brauchen ist
eine konsequente Zusammenarbeit mit der
digitalen Zivilgesellschaft die viel zu
oft in der letzten Zeit vergessen wurde
in der Vergangenheit haben wir Millionen
Steuergelder für Projekte ausgegeben die
dann nach wenigen Tagen gescheitert sind
deshalb feiern wir in dieser Koalition
endlich die Expertise ernst nehmen und
auf sie hören denn anders als in der
Vergangenheit wollen wir uns nicht zu
fein sein zum eigenen Schaden richtige
Hinweise anzunehmen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
liebe Kollegin Kahn ich wollte ihnen
Redefluss nicht unterbrechen aber wenn
sie mich beim nächsten Mal begrüßen zu
Beginn der Rede wäre ich sehr dankbar
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
Johannes Schätzel
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen die
gigabit-strategie der Bundesregierung
ist die erste ganzheitliche Strategie
die sich mit dem Infrastrukturausbau in
unserem Land beschäftigt diese Strategie
sie wurde über Wochen in
vertrauensvoller Zusammenarbeit erstellt
und sehr geehrter Minister ich muss an
dieser Stelle sagen ich finde sie sehr
gelungen
Herr Minister
sie haben es aber auch angesprochen wir
brauchen diese Strategie weil es kaum
ein Thema gibt dass wir über so viele
Jahre immer und immer wieder gleich
diskutieren ein Thema bei dem wir uns
eigentlich alle in der Zielsetzung
vollkommen einig sind und dennoch ein
Thema bei dem wir gemessen an unseren
eigenen Zielen nicht schnell genug
Vorankommen es geht um ungehaltene
Versprechungen es geht allen um einen
Flicken Teppich von Förderungen und das
wichtigste es wurde jahrelang auf die
falsche Technologie gesetzt Kupfer statt
Glasfaser vergoldete koaxialnetze die
Anbieter hat das zwar gefreut
Deutschland aber nicht
Liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen wir ändern
das die gigabit-strategie setzt auf auf
den Koalitionsvertrag der
Koalitionsvertrag besagt Glasfaser in
jedes Haus Glasfaser in jede Wohnung wir
haben verstanden dass es die Glasfaser
braucht um die Datenmengen von morgen zu
transportieren die
gigabit-gesellschaft meine Damen meine
Herren darf im Jahr 2022 keine leere
Worthülse mehr sein moderne Arbeiten
moderne Produktion wir brauchen Gigabit
fähige Netze und deswegen steht unser
Ziel bis 2025 wollen wir 50 Prozent der
Haushalte mit Glasfaser Anschluss
versorgt haben und danach geht es weiter
Liebe Union ein Wort zu ihrem Antrag sie
haben einen Antrag gestellt und sie
fordern jetzt jetzt fordern sie 15
Milliarden für den digitalen
Infrastrukturausbau und sie fordern
dabei ich zitiere aus ihrem Antrag
gigabit-netze bereitstellen sowie den
Glasfaserausbau voranbringen ich finde
es schwierig dass wir wieder von so wie
sprechen wir haben jahrelang den
gleichen Fehler gemacht Kupfer und
koaxial zu fördern jetzt wieder beides
da machen wir nicht mit das ist keine
gute Idee
und damit wir unsere Ziele tatsächlich
erreichen werden wir Tempo ins Verfahren
bekommen durch schlankere und digitale
Genehmigungsverfahren wir begegnen den
tiefbaukapazitäten mit alternativen
verlegemethoden und wir schaffen ein
Förderinstrument was auf der einen Seite
den Markt zu Tempo animiert und auf der
anderen Seite genau da einspringt wo es
notwendig ist wir sprechen von
Potenzialanalysen wir sprechen von
Abstimmungen mit privaten Kapitalgebern
wir sprechen an dieser Stelle von
Dutzenden von Maßnahmen die am Ende
zusammenpassen um unsere Ziele zu
erreichen
neben dem
Glasfaserausbau kümmert sich die
Gigabyte Strategie auch um das Thema
Mobilfunk Ziel ist und bleibt eine
flächendeckende Mobilfunkversorgung auch
mit dem neuesten Mobilfunkstandard dafür
setzen wir auf Bund länderabstimmungen
wir setzen auf vereinheitlichte Vorgaben
auf einem klaren Rechtsrahmen und
genauso werden wir das Ziel erreichen 5g
in jeder Stadt 5g auf dem Land auf jeder
Autobahn und in jedem Zug genau dafür
ist dieses Papier gut und ich freue mich
auf die weitere Zusammenarbeit auf einen
Fortschritt in digitale Infrastruktur
vielen Dank
Johannes Schätzel vom Beruf Informatiker
hat hier gleich mal als erstes den
Minister gelobt da haben wir heute ja
auch schon anderes aus der Ampel gehört
und der hat hier noch mal dargestellt
das ist genau richtig ist Schritt für
Schritt bis zum Jahr 2025 50 Prozent
Glasfaser und dann bis zum Jahr 2030 und
so muss man es machen sagt Viertel Mark
wir das jetzt für die cocs
Digitalisierung zu nutzen ist zentral
für die soziale wirtschaftliche und
gesellschaftliche Teilhabe und eine
faire ökologische Transformation der
Gesellschaft diesen im Koalitionsvertrag
verankerten Grundgedanken spiegelt die
beschlossene
digitalstrategie bislang nur bedingt
wieder der Erfolg der digitalen
Strategie hängt nun stark von der
Umsetzung der beschlossenen Projekte ab
die Strategie lässt wichtige Punkte
weiter offen beispielsweise das
digital-budget das im Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart wurde und bisher nicht im
Haushalt hinterlegt ist liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das sind leider
nicht meine Worte das ist die
Pressemitteilung der Grünen im Deutschen
Bundestag
wir sind uns wohl alle ein ich liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass sie in der
Opposition wohl besser aufgehoben waren
das Problem ist aber sie regieren jetzt
ihre vorgelegte digitalstrategie steht
exemplarisch für die Arbeit der Ampel
Bundesregierung in den ersten neun
Monaten sie starten mit großen
Ankündigungen von Aufbruch und
Fortschritt und verlieren sich dann in
koalitionsstreitereien über Ideologie
und Zuständigkeiten das ist nicht gut
meine Damen und Herren sie verabschieden
eine dachstrategie nach der anderen aber
unter dem Dach hängt der Haussegen Chef
regieren heißt Verantwortung zu
übernehmen und Herr Kollege Funke Kaiser
bitte kommen die nicht jetzt schon
wieder mit 16 Jahren der unionsgeführten
Bundesregierung das ist ihre
digitalstrategie das ist ihre Bilanz der
digitalpolitik
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag schreiben Sie
Kompetenzen der Bundesregierung werden
neu geordnet und neu gebündelt doch
jetzt machen sie das glatte Gegenteil
für die datenstrategie ist das
Verkehrsministerium das
Wirtschaftsministerium und das
Innenministerium zuständig drei für das
zentrale Thema der digitalen Identitäten
ist das Innenministerium das
Bundeskanzleramt das Verkehrsministerium
das Finanzministerium und das
Wirtschaftsministerium 5 verantwortlich
wer blickt da noch durch
was ist jetzt braucht ist ein echtes
digitalministerium das auch wirklich mit
dem nötigen Rückhalt und der Kompetenz
der digitalpolitik vorantreibt wie wir
sind unserem Antrag von CDU und CSU
fordern weshalb das dringend nötig ist
zeigt auch das Arbeitsministerium von
Hubertus Heil Arbeitgebern wird verboten
Informationen zum Arbeitsverhältnis per
E-Mail statt per Post zu schicken und
auch die Flexibilisierung von
Arbeitszeiten hat das Arbeitsministerium
wieder aus der digitalstrategie
herausgestrichen so wird es nichts mit
dem digitalen Aufbruch liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen aber liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zur ambitionslos die Ziele der
digitalstrategie auch sein mögen nicht
einmal diese werden umsetzen denn die
Lichter für die Leuchtturmprojekte
dieser digitale Strategie bleiben ohne
dass digital-budget leider aus wieso
haben sie ein solches digital-bud
eigentlich nicht schon längst
vorgestellt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Ampel wie als Union haben
schon vor Monaten in einem Antrag zum
Haushalt darauf hingewiesen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir machen in
unserem Antrag 30 konkrete Vorschläge
für die Digitalisierung in unserem Land
ihre digitalstrategie hingegen zeigt
Bedenken first digital second oder ob es
oder um es mit den Worten des
digitalpolitischen Sprechers der Grünen
zu sagen die digitalstrategie lässt Luft
nach oben herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Tobias bacherle
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass die
Bundesregierung sich mit der
digitalstrategie so intensiv mit
digitalpolitik beschäftigt das ist gut
das ist notwendig schließlich haben wir
uns im Koalitionsvertrag einen
strammesprogramm vorgenommen was
notwendig war mussten wir um dieses Land
endlich zu modernisieren endlich fit für
die 20er Jahre dieses Jahrhunderts zu
machen ich will positiv bleiben Liebe
Union herzlichen Glückwunsch ich will
gratulieren dass sie sich in diesem
Antrag so gut die Lieblingsprojekte aus
digitalstrategie und Koalitionsvertrag
zusammengesucht haben und damit ja auch
die verpassten Chancen ihre
Regierungsarbeit so deutlich aufarbeiten
aber lieber mag biadacz eine Sache wir
sind da an der Stelle eben auch bereit
Manöverkritik zu üben während wir
regieren als Fraktion um eben noch
schneller und während der Regierungszeit
und nicht erst danach noch besser zu
werden
in unserer in unserer digital oder in
der digitalstrategie der Bundesregierung
stellen wir bei der Digitalisierung den
Menschen in den Mittelpunkt Menschen
müssen selbstbestimmt über Ihre Daten
bestimmen können und digital teilhaben
können und das ist keine Logik die an
unseren Außengrenzen ändern darf wir
wollen ja schließlich keine gläserne
Bürgerin mit Ihren Daten und ihren
Profil am Ende autoritären Regime auf
dem digitalen Silbertablet Servieren für
unsere Regierungspolitik ist ja auch der
zivilgesellschaftliche Austausch ganz
besonders wichtig und damit das eben
auch weltweit und in der Außenpolitik
funktionieren kann müssen wir Menschen
vor Zensur Überwachung oder auch
abgeschalteten Internet schützen und uns
international dafür einbringen
und gerade in den letzten Monaten sollte
allen klar geworden sein wie ein
notwendig es ist digitalpolitik global
und sicherheitspolitisch zu denken das
geht die Bundesregierung an dazu kurz
zwei Highlights mit der geplanten data
MBC datenausweis sitzt wie das dann im
Behörden Deutsch so schön heißt schaffen
wir einen digitalen Zwilling unserer
Regierungsdaten und dadurch Absicherung
und Beständigkeit für unser Handeln auch
in krassen Krisen und mit dem Engagement
bei Gothic ein Projekt welches
verwaltungsdigitalisierung weltweit
stärkt unterstützen wir die digitale
Souveränität von Menschen und die
Zugänge und Möglichkeiten von
Regierungen weltweit und ja ich bin mir
sicher dabei können auch wir noch was
von anderen lernen also die
technologische Entwicklung ist rasant
Innovation hält sich im Zweifel eben
nicht an Grenzen es ist also eine
Notwendigkeit digitalpolitik
international zu denken einfach weil
unsere ganze Welt eine digitale ist
und trotzdem müssen wir bei uns anfangen
überwachungsgesamtrechnung statt einer
absurden chatkontrolle
sicherheitslückenmanagement und eine
ordentliche Finanzierung für digitale
Projekte und unsere globale
Verantwortung müssen unser Beitrag sein
ist dann die Grundlage worauf ich mich
freue aufbauend auf diesem Auftakt eine
internationale digitalstrategie
anzugehen für ein demokratisches offenes
partizipatives und selbstbestimmtes
Internet vielen Dank
Tobias bachale für die bündnisgrillen
der Bundestag diskutiert über die
digital und gigabit-strategie der
Bundesregierung und die nächste die das
tut ist Carolin Wagner für die SPD
Menschen neue Orte zu erkunden
langsamste Freunde wiederzusehen günstig
zum Arbeitsplatz zu pendeln Mobilität
bewegt uns und mobilität ist ein
Zukunftsthema das gleiche gilt für die
Digitalisierung und zusammengenommen
heißt das in der Mobilität der Zukunft
spielen Daten eine entscheidende Rolle
und wie wir die Mobilität der Zukunft in
unsere Gegenwart holen das steht in der
digitalstrategie als eines der 18
Leuchtturmprojekte in der
digitalstrategie ist ein Ökosystem für
Mobilitätsdaten genannt dieses Ökosystem
für Mobilitätsdaten umfasst zum einen
den mobility data space der Anfang
dieses Jahres ans Netz gegangen ist mit
dem mobility data space stellen wir ein
technisches System bereit mit dem
Mobilitätsdaten fair geteilt werden
können das mag jetzt abstrakt klingen
aber dieser Datenraum birgt die
Grundlage für zahlreiche ganz konkrete
innovative anwenden
zum Beispiel
zum Beispiel für neue
Mobilitätsdienstleistungen wie Apps die
individuell und standortbezogen anzeigen
wo in der Nähe ein E-Bike oder E-Roller
zur Verfügung stehen oder die den
eigenen Standort in einer fremden Stadt
einen Taxi melden dass man sich über
diese App ruft und ganz wichtig dabei im
mobility data space werden die
Eigentumsrechte der datenbesitzer:innen
an Ihren Daten gewahrt und
Datenschutzstandards geachtet und das
ist ein großer Unterschied zu den
intransparenten Datenspeicher Giganten
Google und Co denen wir mit ihren
haifischartigen Geschäftsmodellen dieses
Feld nicht konkurrenzlos überlassen
wollen nicht überlassen dürfen wird die
Kolleginnen
den anderen Teil dieses Ökosystems für
Mobilitätsdaten liefert die Mobilität
die Mobilität enthält Daten aus dem
öffentlichen Verkehr etwa Fahrpläne der
Bahn Echtzeitdaten aus dem ÖPNV aber
eben auch allgemeine Wetterdaten und nun
gilt es als nächsten Schritt beide
Plattformen erstens zu verknüpfen
zweitens weiterhin dafür zu sorgen sie
mit hochwertigen Daten zu befüllen und
sie drittens strategisch sinnvoll
weiterzuentwickeln und für den mobility
data space gilt ferner möglichst
vielfältige datengeber die
Automobilindustrie
leitbetriebssystembetreiber die Bahn
Busanbieter aber eben auch Kommunen und
so weiter für die Teilnahme zu gewinnen
und zu guter Letzt gilt es diesen
Datenraum nicht an den
landesgrenzenenden zu lassen sondern ihn
als europäischen Datenraum mit unseren
Nachbarländern zu verknüpfen und wenn
sie mir werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Union jetzt immer noch sagen das
entspricht keiner Strategie dann
erinnert mich das eigentlich nur noch an
den Wunder
Pumuckl der sagt Weinen ist ja sehr
schön aber langweilig wenn es keiner
hört mit herzlichen Dank
Verknüpfung mit den europäischen
Nachbarländern das Stichwort im
europaindex für die digitale Wirtschaft
und Gesellschaft liegt Deutschland im
Moment nur auf Platz 13 von 27
EU-Staaten bei der Durchdringung von
Unternehmer also Integration der
Datentechnik sogar nur auf Platz Nummer
16 das muss sich ändern Markus Reichel
jetzt für die cdu/csu
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen also ich habe
mir heute schon gedacht dass wir in den
ersten Minuten wieder mal die ersten
Münzen ins 16 Jahre Phrasenschwein
hineinschmeißen müssen ein Jahr nach der
Wahl im übrigen aber dass wir heute wenn
wir über die deutsche digitalstrategie
sprechen bis zur Berlusconi kommen Herr
Zimmermann das hätte ich mir echt nicht
erwartet
lassen Sie uns jetzt mal aber ein
bisschen genauer über das Thema der
sicheren digitalen Identitäten sprechen
warum sind sie so wichtig da gibt es das
standardbeispiel also dass ich jetzt von
meinem von meiner Couch in Dresden eben
ganz bequem hier meine Wohnung ummelden
kann das ist ein super Sache aber
zweites Beispiel wozu das hinführen soll
die Ermöglichung eines sicheren eine
souveränen Umgangs mit Daten
Gesundheitsdaten Forschungsdaten und
etwas was viel zu kurz kommt im Kontext
der Modernisierung auch unserer
Industrie für das Internet of things
benötigen wir sichere digitale
Identitäten von Menschen aber eben auch
in der Zukunft von Maschinen und kurz
gesagt hier steckt ein ungeheures
Potenzial zu unserer aller nutzen und
eine enorme Chance auch für die
Entbürokratisierung
Herr Minister wissen sie haben bei der
Vorstellung der digitalstrategie
versprochen wir verlieren uns nicht in
Zukunftsvisionen wir gehen jetzt die
Digitalisierung ganz konkret an und ich
muss auch sagen ich finde es
hervorragend dass auch sie in der
digitalstrategie die sicheren digitalen
Identitäten als eines der Projekte mit
Hebelwirkung ganz ganz oben auf die
Agenda setzen und nach ihrer Ansage
hatte ich natürlich jetzt auch gehofft
dass wir viele ganz konkrete Dinge dazu
lesen werden ich muss allerdings sagen
schon bereits bei den Zielstellungen
fehlanzeige
erstes Ziel was sie sagen im mindestens
fünf Wirtschaftssektoren soll bis 2025
eine staatlich bereitgestellte digitale
ID zur Identifizierung genutzt werden da
sage ich warum denn gerade fünf warum
nicht zehn welches Sektoren sind gemeint
welche Anwendungsfälle ein zweites Ziel
was Sie angeben der Personalausweis der
Führerschein sollen bis 2025 auch als
digitale Nachweise zur Nutzung mit
mobilen Endgeräten verfügbar sein dazu
sage ich ich finde es toll dass die gute
Projekte der CDU geführten
Bundesregierung fortführen aber es kann
doch nicht sein dass sie sich darauf
beschränken jetzt 2022 nur die Projekte
der Vorgängerregierung als Ziel zu
erklären und zu Ende zu bringen da muss
es doch mehr geben
so viel aber zu ihren Zielen bei der
Umsetzungsplanung sieht es ehrlich
gesagt auch nicht viel besser aus da
fehlen ganz maßgebliche ganz konkrete
Dinge sie lassen offen wie Sie vorgehen
wollen um sichere digitale Identitäten
besser im Markt zu verbreiten konkret
denke ich daran dass wir mal dafür
sorgen dass der Chip auf diesem
Personalausweis der im übrigen im
schönen Dresden produziert wird dass der
mal freigeschalten wird und dass das
dass es dazu auch eine entsprechende
Marketingkampagne gibt zweitens sie
lassen offen was mit den
schaufensterprojekten des bmwk
eigentlich passieren soll die sie
stecken eine ganze Menge Geld hier in
tolle Projekte aber nutzen sie das auch
sie lassen offen wie die Bundesregierung
eine digitale Identität in Europa
etablieren möchte suchen sie ihre
interapparate nationale Lösungen oder
eine neue für alle und schließlich sie
lassen offen wie die Bundesregierung
überhaupt zu einer europäischen ID
Wallet steht das Thema wird überhaupt
nicht angesprochen ihr papiertätigt
keine Aussage zu den europäischen Pilot
Arbeiten an denen die Bundesregierung
mitarbeitet also mein Fazit digitale
Identität ist eines ihrer hebelprojekte
sehr gut und trotzdem ist es erstaunlich
unkonkret das ist nicht gut und sie
gehen kaum nennenswert hier über die
Pläne der alten Bundesregierung hinaus
und die Chancen des europäischen eiders
novellierungsprozesses nutzen sie leider
gar nicht unter digital first da
verstehen wir etwas anderes Herr Wissing
sie haben versprochen er ist ganz
konkret zu machen wir warten darauf
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion Rösner
jetzt die bündnisgrüne ist Vorsitzende
im Ausschuss für digitales des Deutschen
Bundestages
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin ich darf ja schon seit
2009 die digitalpolitik und auch den
Breitbandausbau hier im Bundestag
begleiten und ich glaube ich muss mal
ein paar Erinnerungslücken füllen also
was haben denn die Vorgängerregierung
gemacht sie haben sich überboten in den
Zielen des Breitbandausbaus
2009 waren es zwei Mbit dann 50 dann 100
dann irgendwann Gigabit und Sie haben
nichts davon erreicht und warum nicht
weil sie nämlich völlig falsche Weichen
gestellt haben sie haben auch die
vectoring-technologie gesetzt und damit
Kupfer aufgepimpt was den
Glasfaserausbau die Grundlage der
digitalpolitik was den Glasfaserausbau
verhindert hat das ist doch alles andere
als ein digitaler Aufbruch
ist die nachhaltigste Technologie das
haben wir hier immer schon gesagt und
sie verbraucht übrigens auch am
wenigsten Energie auch deshalb brauchen
wir die Migration von Kupfer ins Glas
und seit Jahren warten die Menschen auf
einen schnellen Internetanschluss sie
kriegten ihn versprochen aber er wurde
nicht ausgebaut und mir ist immer noch
schleierhaft dass in neubausgebieten es
nicht standardmäßig passiert das
Glasfaser bis zu den Häusern ausgebaut
wird da müssen wir ans TKG ran lieber
Herr Wissing da werden wir zusammen dran
arbeiten damit wir bis 2030 alle
Wohnungen mit Glasfaser versorgt
bekommen muss jetzt ordentlich Dampf
gemacht werden beim flächendeckenden
Ausbau und das geht übrigens auch für
den mobilfunkausbau im ländlichen Raum
die Anhörung am Montag hat gezeigt es
liegt viel Arbeit vor uns um die
Zeitpläne einzuhalten dafür müssen wir
die Länder mit ins Boot nehmen die viele
Verwaltungsverfahren vereinfachen müssen
damit Genehmigungen schnell erteilt
werden das ist dringend notwendig
wir erwarten aber auch
wir erwarten aber auch von der
TK-Branche und auch von der Baubranche
dass sie interne Verfahren vereinfachen
beschleunigen verbraucherfreundlicher
gestalten dass sie gegenüber
Mitbewerbern und VerbraucherInnen und
Kommunen verbindliche Angaben machen und
sich an die abgegebenen
Selbstverpflichtungen auch halten denn
nur wenn wir alle zusammen an einem
Strang ziehen und zwar in die gleiche
Richtung nur dann schaffen wir die
gigabit-ausbau und der ist ja die
Grundlage für die digitalpolitik für die
digitalstrategie und für einen modernes
Land vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Matthias David Nives für die
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
[Applaus]
Daten retten Leben das mag in der
Theorie stimmen aber bis wir in Deutsch
Kollege hier fehlt die Begrüßung auch
noch mal offiziell jetzt unterbreche ich
dann noch mal guten morgen zusammen und
guten Morgen
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
Daten retten Leben das merken der
Theorie stimmen aber in der Praxis haben
wir da in Deutschland noch einen weiten
Weg vor uns und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass wir nicht nur eine digitalstrategie
auflegen sondern das war auch der
Umsetzung Gas geben insbesondere im
Bereich Gesundheit und Pflege
im Bereich Gesundheit und Pflege möchte
ich gerne auf drei Punkte eingehen
erstens unsere Ziele zweitens unserer
konkreten Projekte und drittens unserer
neuen Arbeitsmodus schauen wir auf die
Ziele davon gibt es exakt zwei und das
ist erstens für die Patientin und
Patienten konkrete Verbesserungen in der
Versorgung zu erreichen und das zweite
Ziel ist dass wir es den Menschen die in
Gesundheit und Pflege arbeiten das Leben
erleichtern in Bürokratie abnehmen damit
sie mehr Zeit und Energie haben für das
woraus ankommt nämlich das Kümmern am
Ende ist nämlich Digitalisierung dafür
da das Leben für die Menschen besser zu
machen
bei den Projekten ist es erste ganz
zentrale Thema die neue digitale
Patientenakte denn die genial wäre es
wenn ich auf meinem Handy sehe welche
Impfung ich schon habe und vielleicht
eine Erinnerung bekomme wenn die in
einer Auffrischung fällig wird wie
sicher würde ich mich fühlen wenn ich
weiß dass wenn ich bei einem Notfall ins
Krankenhaus komme und die Ärztinnen und
Pflegefachkräfte direkt sehen welche
Vorerkrankungen ich habe und welche
Medikamente ich nehme um Komplikationen
zu vermeiden das will ich und das wollen
auch die Menschen zu Hause in Kusel in
Kaiserslautern und im Rest der Republik
das brauchen wir standardmäßig dass alle
damit arbeiten dass alle des einfachen
bequem bekommen in Deutschland und dabei
ist auch wichtig dass jeder und jede
einzelne die volle Kontrolle über seine
eigenen Daten behält und auch immer
sagen kann ich möchte das nicht oder ich
möchte bestimmte Dinge sperren oder
Zugänge verhindern das muss jeder für
sich selbst entscheiden können und dafür
tragen wir Sorge
zu unseren Projekten gehört aber auch
dass wir eine digitale
gesundheitsagentur brauchen und zwar mit
einem ganz klaren Auftrag nämlich den
die Menschen in den Vordergrund zu
stellen die im Gesundheits- und
Pflegewesen arbeiten und neue
Anwendungen und Infrastrukturen so zu
entwickeln einzuführen damit sie in der
Praxis funktionieren und Mehrwerte
bieten und eben nicht dazu führen dass
im Alltag die Dinge lahmgelegt werden
das muss der Auftrag für die neue
digitale gesundheitsagentur sein die
Nutzenden im Fokus
das dritte was wir brauchen ist dass wir
uns anschauen wie können wir die
Forschung Stärken wie schaffen wir es
das auch in Deutschland Daten in der
Forschung besser genutzt werden können
und wir sicherstellen dass neue
Medikamente und Therapien eben nicht nur
in Asien und in Kalifornien entstehen
sondern genauso in Mainz und in
Ingelheim
und für diese Projekte die sind alle
schwierigen kompliziert brauchen wir
einen Modus der Zusammenarbeit mit den
wichtigen Akteuren im Gesundheitswesen
mit den Kassen Apothekern Ärzten um nur
einige zu nennen dazu gehört aber auch
dass wir aktiv mit den Verantwortlichen
für Sicherheit und Datenschutz
zusammenarbeiten schon jetzt im Vorfeld
um gemeinsam gute Lösungen zu finden
denn ich bin überzeugt davon wenn wir es
ernst meinen kriegen wir das auch hin
damit Daten Leben retten und zwar
endlich auch in Deutschland danke schön
Matthias David Nives ist 36 Jahre jung
ein Bundestag hat auch die Begrüßung
vergessen aber das war nicht böse
gemeint sondern eher der naseität
geschuldet